we have to take our hats off to you the
late great Robin Williams for your
amazing ad lib work on Aladdin the genie
brings non-stop laughs to the movie and
that's thanks to you not only the script
writers your improvisation skills are
second to none all those accents and
crazy voices make the genie one of the
most loved characters in the Disney
verse then what makes your performance
even more incredible is that you came up
with so much of it off the top of your
head is every fun so many Disney scenes
are iconic we can't imagine them being
any other way but did you know lots of
them were actually improvised keep
watching to the end to discover which
hilarious scene and frozen to wasn't
even in the script tell me you're older
and thus all-knowing do you ever worry
about the notion then nothing is
permanent Aladdin the genie in Aladdin
is one of Robin Williams most iconic
roles and a lot of that is down to his
own lines the movie makers wanted the
comedian to play the genie from the
get-go and actually wrote this script
with him in mind but ironically Robin
improvised a huge amount of his lines
take the Pinocchio gag for example I'll
do it Oh Robin totally came up with that
hilarious moment when they tried it out
with test audiences it was so popular
that the filmmakers had to go back and
add extra frames to the scene this is
almost unheard of as animated movies
usually have lots of frames cut in the
edit suite Robin also ad-lib calling
Aladdin ow
and that's stuck too we often get
little-known nuggets of information when
Disney adds the commentary to the extras
on the DVD release of a movie and when
Aladdin was released on DVD in 1994 the
co-directors and co-producer added their
commentary to the film John Musker Ron
Clements and Amy Pell revealed just how
much Robin Williams ad-lib and not just
as the genie but also as the narrator
the narrator's lines at the beginning
were scripted but when they fell flat
the crew brought Robin a bunch of props
to use as inspiration once he was done
goofing off in the studio they picked
out the best
bids Toy Story Robin Williams improv
skills in Aladdin are so inspiring that
even other actors measured themselves
against his ad-lib wit take Tim Allen
the voice of Buzz Lightyear Allen used
to love ad libbing when he filmed Toy
Story but the movie makers well not so
much Allen revealed that when he
ad-libbed it was nothing like Robin
Williams performance when he did Aladdin
he admitted it wasn't a happy moment for
the animators if what he said was funny
they knew they'd have to go back and
reanimate the scene so which of Allen's
ad-lib moments made the cut when woody
tells buzz you're a toy Allen came up
with his own retort off-the-cuff you're
a sad strange little man and you have my
pity but all good things come to an end
and the movie makers weren't quite so
indulgent as time went on Allen admitted
that eventually they'd tell him to just
read the script
ouch the lion king when Simba asks Timon
to create a diversion to distract the
hyenas the meerkat comes out with one of
the best lines in the Lion King he
replies dude wretched dragon do the hula
Nathan Lane the voice behind him own
actually ad-lib that line it was so well
received that movie makers ran with it
with the gag extending to Timon and
Pumbaa Hawaiian luau Timon points out
how good Pumbaa would taste to lure the
hyenas over in the live-action remake of
the 1994 animation however this
improvised scene is changed rather than
do a hula dance Timon makes a reference
to Beauty and the Beast by singing be
our guest
he still points out how good Pumbaa
would taste but this time it's an
Illumina French accent speaking of
Beauty and the Beast
there were improvised lines in the final
cut of that movie too
Beauty and the Beast Cogsworth and lumi
a provided a lot of comedy and Beauty
and the Beast and it wasn't all scripted
the candlestick in the clock riff off of
each other a lot especially during their
interactions with the Beast so it's not
a total surprise that some of the
funniest lines were improvised remember
that scene when the Beast is out in the
snow he tells Cogsworth lumière wants to
do something special for Belle but he
doesn't know what Cogsworth replies well
there's the usual things flowers
chocolates promises you don't intend to
keep it's such a funny moment and what
makes it even funnier is that the actor
behind Cogsworth voice David Ogden
steers ad lib that line the directors
liked it so much it made the final cut
Alice in Wonderland back in the day Walt
Disney sometimes used the actors as
models this was so the animators could
capture their movement as reference for
their cartoon counterparts and on one
such occasion the ad-libs lines were so
good they actually made the final cut
the scene in the Mad Hatter's Tea Party
from Alice in Wonderland edwin who
voices the Mad Hatter was given a load
of props to play with at a tea party
table on the soundstage and so was Jerry
Colonna who voices the March Hare their
slapstick humour funny lines and gags
were almost all entirely improvised
the intention was for the Disney
animators to get their movements but the
words were so good straight off the bass
that they kept them you can even watch
the footage of the process before we
reveal which part of frozen 2 was
improvised we want to make sure you'll
be the first to watch our latest Disney
videos so if you haven't already
subscribed to the things and tap that
notification bell if you're watching on
your phone go to your YouTube settings
and turn on your notifications now back
to ad living Pirates of the Caribbean
the curse of the Black Pearl Johnny
Depp's popular line savvy in Pirates of
the Caribbean the curse of the Black
Pearl were actually improvised the actor
kept using it throughout the movies he
also ad-libbed the line towards the end
of the movie bring me that horizon but
that's not all there was a whole ad
libbed rift that sadly didn't make the
final cut but the deleted scene can be
seen on the DVD release of birth of the
Black Pearl Lee Arenberg the actor who
plays pin tell revealed that he and Depp
improvised a scene that led to rather
funny consequences it happens when
pintle corners Jack Sparrow in the caves
of Isla de Muerta they have a
conversation about the word parlay this
was meant to end when Jack explains it
was the French who thought of parle but
deaf and Arenberg
start improvising about the French
my brother bear improvisation is a
seriously impressive skill to have as an
actor that's particularly the case when
you're a child and your ad libbing off
another actor's mistake that's what
happened during the recording a brother
bear
Joaquin Phoenix slipped up with one of
his lines as Kenai accidentally
referring to kotas friend as binky
instead of Bucky
the young actor behind kotas voice
Jeremy Suarez at a lightning-fast
response it was so funny it made the cut
his name's Bucky it was a pine nut
Zootopia Jason Bateman got the chance to
do a lot of improv in his role as
cunning fox Nick Wilde and Zootopia in
an interview Bateman revealed that there
was lots of room to make stuff up during
the recording the actor explained that
it was a team effort with them all
working together to make each other
laugh there was so much add living that
he forgets how much of the dialogue in
the movie was written or scripted he was
keen to point out however that they
didn't need to make up new lines the
writers did a great job putting it all
together but the actor thought maybe
they wanted to hear some different words
the ice cream parlour scene is one such
moment that was thanks to Batemans
improvisation skills Nick wants to buy a
jumbo pot but pretends to lose his
wallet forcing Judy to pay for him and
it turns out that Bateman came up with
that whole scenario while he was in the
recording booth impressive work Hercules
before Cheyenne Jackson took on the role
of Hades in descendants three James
Woods provided the villains voice in the
animated movie Hercules and James
brought a lot of his own ideas to the
role in an interview the actor revealed
that right from the get-go he was
improvising his own lines the first line
he had was I am Hades Lord of the
underworld and he outright told the
moviemakers it wasn't a funny line so
they invited him to show them how he'd
do it and he came up with his own
version in fact he ad-libbed the whole
scene and then almost every line he did
for the movie was ad-libbed James even
says he came up with the idea of Hades
hair being on fire and that
was inspired by John Travolta and
Saturday Night Fever James also admitted
he came up with a lot of bad lives in
Surf's Up - James still feels very
fondly towards the fast-talking fiend
Hades in 2017 he revealed on Twitter
that Hades is one of his personally
cherished creations and he can certainly
take a lot of credit for creating those
characters as he points out he got to do
a lot of improvisation on the voice work
for the movie frozen - Josh GAD the
actor who voices Olaf is an improv
legend in the first frozen movie he got
to ad-lib a lot of his own lines most
notably when he first meets Anna
Kristoff and Sven but he managed to top
that in frozen - remember the scene when
Olaf is calling out for Sven in the
Enchanted Forest and starts calling out
for Samantha it's right before he
launches into his big song when I am
older it's one of the funniest moments
in this equal even Olaf finds it funny
because he doesn't even know a Samantha
well what makes it even more hilarious
is that Josh made up that line on this
spot the actor revealed on Twitter that
it's never ceased to amaze him how he's
allowed to improv something clinically
insane in a sound booth and then the
best animators in the world take his
nonsense and bring it to life and that's
throughout the process of making both
films he uploaded the samantha scene to
his social media post proving that he's
one of the best add livers out there
it's a favorite moment in the movie not
just for fans but also for the voice
cast themselves Evan Rachel Wood who
voices clean.i Doudna tweeted Josh to
say she can't stop quoting that line
he's sweetly responded by saying that
there even as his girls can't stop
singing the lullaby she performs in the
movie all is found which improvised
scene do you think is the best be sure
to let us know in the comments please
give this video a big thumbs up we'll
see you next time thanks for watching
the things
you